that was only later with the arrival of
the Ottoman Empire that coffee
eventually spread to other regions in
the Middle East and eventually Beyond by
the year 1600 or so coffee was
widespread across multiple continents it
was at that point had reached Europe and
India and many other places even as it
spread it was still used primarily at
first by sufis in their mystical
practices used in a very practical sense
but as it spread wider and time went
went on a lot of people also started
to actually enjoy the drink itself it
caught the attention of people who just
liked to drink it without any other kind
of practical usages for it and so coffee
houses were opened across the Ottoman
Empire where people could gather drink
coffee and discuss things with their
friends things like politics or or
religion or any subject really